Stealing a colleague’s birth control should
get you fired from any normal workplace,
but it won’t at the "NCIS" office… and DiNozzo
is just the start of the show’s problems.
Procedural crime dramas have a way of manipulating
the reality-based aspects of their characters'
jobs. In order to fast track some of the scenes
that would normally involve a lab filled with a
team of scientists, it sort of makes sense for
a TV show to speed up the forensic process.
In the case of "NCIS," Abby and Ducky's
jobs wouldn't exist in real life.
"Alright."
We don't mean that forensic analysts and medical
examiners aren't actual jobs — obviously,
they are. However, a forensic analyst and medical
examiner wouldn't work within an NCIS building;
they wouldn't have a direct line of communication
to an NCIS agent, nor would there only be one of
each. A real-life NCIS field office would work
with local state or county medical examiners
and labs for forensic evidence and each one would
certainly have more than one person working there.
Gibbs' team also isn't the only group of field
agents that operates in that branch of NCIS.
In that case, Abby and Ducky would have to keep up
with Gibbs' cases and every other agent's cases.
If that were true for real-world counterparts,
the overtime costs alone would be astronomical.
For the sake of television, it's pretty much
a necessity to keep the show's pacing punchy
and exciting. Otherwise, each episode
would be a victim of the red-taped,
glacial pace of real-time forensic sciences.
In the very first episode of "NCIS,"
titled "Yankee White," the death of
a Marine on Air Force One triggers a
mess of jurisdictional complications.
The ultimate question of this episode is
who claims jurisdiction over the death
of a Naval commander who dies on Air
Force One? Do Gibbs and his team have
any right to fly away with the president's
plane in order to hold such jurisdiction?
Ok — let's break this one down. The
second the president walks off the plane,
the Secret Service loses jurisdiction,
and it gets handed off to the FBI.
But in accordance with SECNAV Instruction,
since NCIS has a horse in this race in the
form of a dead officer, "joint criminal
investigations [...] conducted with the
FBI [...] designate NCIS as having exclusive
responsibility." So, in the real world,
NCIS actually would have jurisdiction
to take custody of the body. But does
that really give them the right to snatch the
president's plane to ensure they keep custody?
And if they can't take the plane,
how is it that we never hear about anyone
getting into trouble for that stunt?
When it comes to forensics, contaminations
are one of the worst mess-ups that can
happen to an investigation. It's also
the case that biohazardous materials,
which can possibly cause illness and
contamination, are frequent fliers in
a medical examiner's field. Ducky, who is
supposed to be the best at what he does,
ought to know how not to contaminate a
forensic lab or spread unsanitary materials.
"Excuse me. Show a little respect,
this is a place of peace and dignity."
In "Sub Rosa," Ducky potentially contaminates
several areas with biohazardous materials. He
meets Abby in her lab after performing
an autopsy. As he enters Abby's area,
we can see he is still in his surgical
gown and there's blood smeared all over
the front. Blood is considered a biohazard
material, and not only does bringing it out
of his lab and into Abby's increase the chances
for an infection to break loose, but it could
potentially contaminate any other evidence
that is present in Abby's workspace. Gross.
In other episodes, Ducky, among other
investigators, commits potential crime
scene contamination through lack of proper
personal protection equipment. The National
Institute of Justice explains that crime scene
investigators must have items such as "gloves,
booties, hair covering, overalls, and mask,"
readily available for a crime scene sweep.
The team encounters their very first
multi-episode "NCIS" villain near
the end of Season 1. By the "NCIS"
Season 2 finale, he's still at large.
But we're more curious about why a standard
criminal investigative team would seemingly
be the sole faction charged with taking down
terrorist Ari Haswari. Gibbs and his agents
typically take on cases that involve far more
standard crimes than counterterrorism. In fact,
real-life NCIS does include counterterrorism
efforts, but that wouldn't include a team like
Gibbs'. The "NCIS" group would probably have
to undergo a lot of extra training dedicated
to counterterrorism that would hardly ever come
up in their day-to-day work. Even after all that,
where exactly is the time to get all their other
case work done if they're going after terrorists?
The real-life counterterrorism portions of NCIS
would take on a case like Ari's, and it would
probably take years of dedicated work and a lot of
information sharing with other federal branches.
It's a safe story arc, especially for the era
in which it was originally aired. In the years
following 9/11, counterterrorism and heavily
inflated patriotism flooded the United States,
making this a TV plotline that went
over well with American audiences.
"NCIS" spent some time in hot water
when fans and critics started asking,
"Is NCIS sexist?" A lot of concerns
over the show's depiction of women
came about because of Michael
Weatherly's character, DiNozzo.
During the first few seasons, DiNozzo and Kate are
constantly bickering about the differences between
men and women all while plopping women into
two-dimensional stereotypical roles and behaviors.
"Tony, how long have you been in here?"
"Long enough to know you can't sing. And
you haven't shaved your legs in a week."
In later seasons, there's a pretty big shift
in DiNozzo and the overall tone of the show,
as audiences grew tired of watching
the same prejudiced banter.
Fans noticed a shift in "NCIS" personalities
around Season 9. But instead of it being
a step away from their initial portrayal
in earlier seasons – which would probably
mean multiple personality rewrites —
the shift was designed to allow the
show's women more depth, as opposed to
the shallowness we'd previously seen.
Apparently, rules are loose guidelines
when it comes to the "NCIS" workplace.
Even someone like DiNozzo should know when to pump
the breaks and start thinking with his
head instead of… his other appendages.
DiNozzo has nearly no filter when it comes to
talking to women, whether it be at work or when
he's off the clock. But since what he does in
his own time is up to him, we're more concerned
when he's trying to pick up women while working
cases. In "Forced Entry," he and Kate are sent
to question a suspect at a base hospital. When
he approaches the desk to ask the Lieutenant on
duty about the suspect, he asks her out to a lunch
date so he can go through some routine questions.
"This is my engagement ring, Agent
DiNozzo. I brought my lunch."
Even after the rejection, DiNozzo continues
to push by saying that engaged is not
technically married and implies she's on
the fence about her wedding. We cringe.
Later, in "Mind Games," he takes a female
colleague's birth control pills and holds
them in the air for her to retrieve like she's
a child, all while saying that she couldn't
possibly need them unless she's seeing someone.
Not a great look, DiNozzo. Not great at all.